et on passe au documentaire la cravate
de mathias thierry etienne chaillou la
cravate se porte plutôt autour du front
qu'autour du coup puisqu'il prend pour
personnage principal un militant
d'extrême droite on en parle après la
bande annonce
ceci est l'histoire d'un jeune militant
politique nommée bastien rémy
il est important de bien un livre mais
tu sais déjà tout ce qui se passe il
était membre d'un parti constitué à
l'extrême droite de l'éventail des
idéologies il avait quelques
responsabilités et rien de très glorieux
et il avait accepté qu'une caméra
s'installe auprès de lui le temps d'une
campagne présidentielle
on découvrira comment les circonstances
poussèrent le jeune homme à s'engager
davantage
à ses côtés on visitera les étages du
parti
un apprivoisera la rhétorique mis en
place pour conquérir l'opinion
et puis on apprendra à identifier les
pièges qui peuvent briser une ambition
le supérieur du héros sentais qu'il
fallait se méfier dames après le match
c'est quand même
mais pouvait-il agir contre cet
attachement étrange qui s'était dit ce
peu à peu entre son militant et l'équipe
de cinéma
la fin du récit est connu c'était en mai
2010 cette dame mais on lira auparavant
tous ceux qui animent et bastien régné
pendant que s'écrivent est une page
nouvelle du roman national
donc c'est parti tout ce que tu nous as
dit on le met dans ce film un mot de
l'originalité principale du film c'est
une originalité de dispositifs c'est à
dire que les deux réalisateurs ont filmé
et suivi ce militantisme qui est encore
le front national à l'époque pas encore
le rassemblement national
ils en ont tiré un texte et une
soumettre le texte à ce jeune homme qui
s'appelle bastien qui donne son avis sur
le texte voilà donc il ya une voix off
qui dit le texte et de temps en temps on
demande à bastien ce qu'il en a pensé
yann vous avez vu le film j'ai trouvé ce
film extraordinaire et là y'a pas
guillaume canet qui vient jouer le rôle
du personnage principal c'est à nos
soeurs et frères
non ma charge arguments j'ai trouvé le
film extrêmement houellebecq est un
cirque est un processus narratif à
l'imparfait sur des scènes qu'on voit au
présent et une mise en abyme du
personnage principal qui est au courant
qu'on fait un film sur lui et qui lie la
voix off qui va être greffé sur les
images alors que ce soit un peu long et
un peu répétitif peut-être que là
l'expression littéraire ne soit pas tant
que ça peut-être exemple avoir un
cerveau vexé ou parler de ratonnades de
déserteurs parce qu'à un moment donné il
a peur de faire taper par des skinheads
avec qui les a mis ses pas très bons en
sachant que les ratonnades c'est quand
même des crimes racistes est vrai que le
cerveau est difficilement avec sable
donc ça veut peut-être plus littéraire
que cette norme a les moyens mais j'ai
trouvé que procédé est extraordinaire
parce que enfin il peut faire des
documentaires d'une manière neuve on
peut pas faire du depardon jusqu'à la
fin de ses jours on peut pas non plus
faire du m6 jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
avec ses voix vous savez près quasiment
préenregistrés que ma des rires
préenregistrés où c'est toujours on
dirait la même fille ou le même type qui
sont payés de cabine dans un sous-sol et
qu on ne ressort que pour les
documentaires et là il ya quelque chose
de la narration qui est presque
romanesque où le temps présent fait
quasiment partie du passé et où il y
effectivement la sensation de lire un
film ou de voir un livre il ya donc un
processus romanesque extrêmement élaboré
une voix agréable à entendre
et je crois du coup un film qui est
beaucoup plus proche de la vérité que
n'aurait été un fil
fiction est beaucoup plus proche d'une
tension narrative que leur était un
documentaire c'est un film qui se situe
entre les deux j'ai mis une excellente
note d'ailleurs ouvert à tout à l'heure
la note en attendait vos objectifs à
vrai dire
alors je ne sais plus quel objectif
génie mais en régie ils le savent et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très beau s'en remettre à la régie
comme ça ça vous dois sera mais c'est
rami yann guyot pas gérard voilà la
blague méritait d'être sinon on se rend
tout de suite après une feinte je peux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
retour sur le plateau de deux corps
humain les chroniques en sont restées
sandrine calvaire à robert thierry chèze
et yann moix alors avant de passer la
parole à catherine j'ajoute quelque
chose quand même c'est que ce jeune
homme qui est assez sympathique on en
vient à connaître son passé et moins de
six tactique est beaucoup moins sympa
est-ce que d'abord il a été ce qui
n'aide donc et un peu engagée lui même
avant il avait quand même des velléités
de devenir tueur de masse alors elle
n'avait que 13 ans comme tout le monde
et ring eh bien justement pas comme tout
le monde et surtout pas comme des gens
qui ne vraiment ne le porte pas sur sur
leur visage et ça fait un peu froid dans
le dos mais catherine quoi vous n'avez
pas à goûter le film et on attend vos
objectifs qui vont peut-être nous le
confiance et touchants et désolant jeudi
clichés parce que franchement quoi
d'neuf que de faire un énième
documentaire sur le front national
appelé maintenant rassemblement national
pour nous parler d'un militant qui a eu
certes un passé violent comme beaucoup
de militants du front des réformes
nationales qui était skinheads rien neuf
sous le soleil je trouvais ça et puis
moi j'ai un truc que je vais le 10g ou
zid suspens c'est ça j'allais dire
sachant choses originales physiquement
cette mise en abyme zébus et franchement
original c'est ce qui rachète tout ce
qui m'a fait tenir jusqu'à la fin
après et franchement j'ai trouvé que
c'était très téléphoner on a
l'impression qu'on découvre les lui
louer c'est comme ça militants du front
national à face a déjà été dit dix fois
c'est embêtant ce ton d'entomologiste
pour parler du vin vous comprenez c'est
panne on est passé pas les insectes et
ils sont passés leurs potions de au
microscope à regarder les instances
tribalise cédant strip tease qu'on voit
ça l'eml i way mais c'est à strip-tease
justement je trouve ridicule et a tué
beaucoup plus fin et beaucoup mieux de
fans ont eu à ben non parce qu'il a du
recul sur très propres outils rémois
savoir anticiper sur le montage
moi je n'ai pas aimé ce ton
d'entomologiste qui est finalement cela
ne plus méprisant et effectivement les
moyennes phrase qui match et un
documentaire saint-élie qu'il représente
un peuple
inquiet mécontent de son sort et
déboussolés par un monde qui tourne trop
vite autour de lui est en panne de rêve
eh bien c'est exactement ça c'est la
patte de rêve d'un monde vous dira
catherine que pendant que vous parliez
de cherry a cumulé les mines
réprobatrice j'ai bien vu que c'était
pas compte en général j'ai mis atypique
les do you know et déstabilisant
atypique on pour le
évidemment la fouille matthieu pita fois
à bas la forme des révolutionnaires j'ai
vu j'ai vu des fictions sur le front
national tout quasiment raté là la porte
du cinéma c'est justement cette cette
méthode de mise en scène et que sa
justice icc au cinéma ça j'ai dit
édifions parce que ce mélange justement
entre les scènes tournées à vif ils ont
il est quand même au bon endroit au bon
moment
notamment lorsque marine le pen vient
cérébrale poule je crois car cette
visite entre les deux tours
c'est un grand moment c'est un moment où
c'est dingue qui soit là a priori ne
filmaient pas marine le pen et d'un seul
coup il est au bon moment et il raconte
et il ya ça et il ya le recul c'est très
rare en un documentaire qui les deux et
que le recul ne soit pas donnée par un
cinéaste omniscient qui est en train de
nous raconter ce qu'on a pas vu parce
que souvent inondée images et jt
stabilisons parce que là il a le souci
ce moment il ya de la sympathie et mer
mais ça c'est pas nouveau on sait bien
que les valeurs mais il n'y a pas qu'un
profit a marqué front national marque
c'est quand même ce qu'on nous raconte
normalement alors qu'on en a à faire et
documenté majan sonné deux petites
choses et de petites réserves que
j'aurais c'est que parfois c'est pas
très clair si le texte reflète les
pensées de ce jeune homme où les pensées
des réalisateurs parfois il ya une
ambiguïté et puis et le deuxième chose
c'est que on interroge jamais trop sur
ses motivations pourquoi il est au front
national pourquoi il milite pour le
front national pendant cette
présidentielle parce que c'est une
menace sérieuse
oui voilà mais il ya un côté on aurait
bien aimé savoir comment il passe de se
vouloir et amérique dans un film de
fiction vous connaissez pas forcément
les mêmes relations dans les frères
dardenne
ces primes sont vraiment ces prix en
plein milieu du mal à mon style c'est le
silence
alors moi j'ai absolument adoré ce film
j'ai atteint mes objectifs
alors c est louis vrai impartiale
sensible j'ai adoré passe parce que j'ai
été profondément cueilli en fait par le
portrait ça ça fait penser évidemment à
madame bovary de flaubert déjà parce que
ben il ya ce support littéraire
l'original est pas et vous habitez
déportés front national j'avais vu
parfois au cinéma je sais pas vous
habitez on n'a pas aussi des mares pays
et moi j'ai adoré parce que donc il ya
déjà bas ce côté 8 flaubert bovary on se
plonge dans un personnage sans justement
j'ai à hauteur d'homme hauteur à hauteur
d'homme moi c'est ça que j'ai aimé
justement au contraire de carrés de
catherine c'est que j'ai aimé le côté
voit la banque juge pas on ne juge
lui-même même course et ça mais oui bien
sûr ils se donnent des coups de fouet
tout seul quand on révèle son passé donc
là l'attentât qu'il a failli faire ça
m'a rappelé le la campagne
présidentielle pendant laquelle j'étais
journaliste sur canal + donc donc je
suis allé à bras chez dans ce village
cultissime pour le front national avec
mon petit micro canal + je vous laisse
imaginer l'accueil que l'ambiance au bon
endroit là et là de pouvoir me plonger
en toute sécurité
derrière mon écran j'ai adoré voilà
clairement et on y voit un bastien d'un
sombre mais aussi lumineux il ya des
aspérités il ya plein de couches c'est
pas la caricature qu'on a tous en tête
les reconnaître en tant qu avec la
nature il est sensible et intelligent il
s'exprime très bien et les voilà oui il
ya des clichés comme ça oui et tant
mieux qu'on montre autre chose aussi
ce que je trouve remarquable c'est qu'on
met en lumière cette génération qui est
née du coup en l'an 2000 et qui a le
droit de vote et qui ne connaît pas jean
marie le pen qui ne connaît pas
l'histoire de l'algérie skhira comment
le front national a été fondée dans
lesquels note alors ça fait un 7 sur 10
mais voilà j'aurais pu monter à 8 900
problème regarder se tenir en 2009
c'est parfait 4e 4 j'ai mis huit mois
j'ai mis sept
ce qui donne une moyenne de serre sur la
note à savoir la moyenne générale que
j'arrive pas c'est donc la cravate de
mathias terry etienne chaillou ses
sorties en salles le 5 février dernier
oui merci pour ce documentaire on vous
la plus dure en fr
[Applaudissements]